we're going off to the um magnetic
resonance imaging center which is a few
hundred yards up the campus
because through brady i've got an
opportunity to see an mri machine i've
never seen one and i really want to see
how it works and actually see what it
feels like to go inside one
this is the seven tesla system so it's
the it's the strongest
human imaging system in the uk
one of the main inventors sir peter
mansfield
worked here in nottingham and won the
2003 nobel prize for medicine
one of the few nobel prizes that has
recently been won by a university in the
uk
and so we're extremely proud of mri as a
technique that started in nottingham and
has gone all over the world
so well so ashley's positioning martin
so his
head's inside the
rf coil the sensitive coil that detects
the
signal that we use to make the images
also i guess making sure that he knows
how to communicate with us in case he
wants to get him
get in touch whilst he's being scanned
with most magnets there's no sensation
at all with a very strong one like this
one some people feel a little bit dizzy
when they just go into the magnet but it
soon passes
so we push people in slowly to try and
avoid the dizziness as much as possible
okay we're gonna start yes i'm ready to
start okay we're gonna start
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so what we do is we we're looking at
signals that come from
hydrogen nuclei
inside water molecules inside the
patient in this case martin's brain so
each hydrogen nucleus when we put
someone into a very strong magnetic
field like this system the hydrogen
nuclei tend to line up with the
field
[Music]
will you be able to hold that for 18
minutes
[Music]
so this is like a hydrogen nuclear
magnet so we can imagine this is the
north pole this is the south pole so
normally in as we're sitting here the
nuclear magnets are kind of randomly
aligned all pointing in sort of
different directions but when we place
someone into a strong magnetic field the
nuclear magnets tend to line up with the
direction of the applied field which
actually in this system is horizontal so
i should probably have it that way
around
how are you doing in there
hi
hey i'm gonna ask you now to move your
head
hello
yeah i'm here
the idea is that these these nuclear
magnets
have a property that when they get
disturbed from being lined up with the
field they tend to precess around it
and the rate at which they go around
depends on how strong
the magnetic field is so in this system
seven tesla system they go around at
about eight at 300 million times per
second at 300 megahertz that sort of
frequency is in the radio wave region of
the electromagnetic spectrum and so
there's an interaction naturally between
the hydrogen nuclear magnets and radio
waves so the way we excite them and make
them precess is by firing a pulse of
radio waves into
in this case martin's brain and then we
get back from the nuclear magnets a kind
of echo of radio waves produced by that
procession of the net nuclear
magnetization
so what we do to make a picture is to
make the magnetic field a little bit
different in different places in the
person's body then the frequency of
procession is different and the
frequency of the signal is different
from different locations so for example
if we make the magnetic field vary along
the axis of someone's body then we can
say that a high field occurs at the top
of the head
a low field at the bottom of the head so
when we see a high frequency signal we
know it came from the top of the head
when we see a low frequency signal we
know it came from the bottom of the head
and we can therefore assign the signal
to position
it was great fun
but the noise is very loud
but it's it stops very suddenly almost
disappointment
so i'm going to take this
did they keep stealing today
so how can you see the iron
if you're looking at the water we can
we're sensitive to the presence of iron
here yeah this is the gray matter here
yes we don't really associate it with
you i mean it doesn't look like me does
it
do you
so can you tell i'm left-handed by
looking at that
me
[Music]